[Music]
this week on
forward this is a unique chance to
actually get a reliable point of view of
electoral politics in the United States
and you know you to your credit you
absolutely gave that to me and it's in
the book so Stephen if someone were to
ask you hey what is this book about what
would you say I would say it's sort of
the most accurate depiction possible of
the inside of a campaign during the last
American election so we were both
tracking down some version of the truth
and some version of the not so distant
future and I think other people who read
this have also gotten the senses like
like they they come back and say you
know I find this eminently plausible um
which is what makes it scary um but also
hopefully
[Music]
valuable it is my pleasure to welcome
back to the podcast the author of the
next war and more importantly my
collaborator and co-author on the brand
new political thriller the last election
stepen Marsh welcome Stephen Andrew how
you doing wow I don't know about you
Stephen but I am super pumped that this
book is actually arriving on bookshelves
and in people's hands and getting out
into the world have you gotten any
feedback uh as yet well I got I mean the
people who read it really liked it I
mean the Publishers Weekly like I I've
never actually had a starred review I've
never had a pre-review for a book go as
well as like like be as nice as that one
where it's like this is a really great
working thriller so I was I was pretty
stoked by that and yeah the response
I've had has been great how about you
yeah same people read it and uh you know
what's funny I don't know if this is an
insult to my previous books but they
were like I'm shocked at how much I like
this right well I mean it makes sense
because it's like a it's you know it's a
it's a thriller like it's a straight
Thriller and but also contains sort of
more you know intimate information about
political life and I think I think those
two in combination are pretty
interesting to read right like I think
those are I think those are those are
sort of more fun things to read than
than just like uh you know politics
right like and it's sort of it's sort of
a different take on it I think and um
it's a very unusual book like I looked
at it again last night and I was like we
have actually written something that's
pretty particular like I don't think
think there's another example of a book
really like this one um but you know I
mean I think that that's exciting too
right like that's that it's it's strange
yeah what multiple people have said to
me is they felt like they learned
something uh and they were entertained
which I feel like his mission
accomplished for us exactly yeah you
know our goal was to entertain yes but
it was also to convey various messages
uh so let's talk about who the heck you
are how you came to this topic how we
ended up writing this book together
so you wrote a book the next civil war
that came out gosh now about 2 years ago
and it it was provocatively meant to say
look uh the United States has very very
clear signs of disintegration that other
societies have gone through and it it's
not exceptional in this regard uh what
was the process like researching that
book uh and then putting it out this
will work of
non-fiction and then the response
thereafter well in in some ways it was
similar to our project because it was
like there were imagined scenarios of
what an American breakdown would look
like and then it was deeply researched
right so I mean what it did was it like
the research was like a lot of phone
calls with experts and also you know we
live in an age of sort of unbelievable
modeling uh from from a lot of different
viewpoints agricultural uh environmental
political uh economic you know like
there just are these really really
functional models and I wanted to sort
of basically take those models and then
put Flesh on the bones right like make
it make people understand what you know
what it means if a hurricane hits New
York which all the models say that it
will right and uh you know so that was
kind of the process there then there was
of course the journalistic process of
like going out and talking to members of
the extreme right which was you know
because I look like one of them it was
very easy for me to you know get access
to them and they were all very polite
and nice to talk to with me and so it
was talking to them going doing things
like going to gun shows in Oklahoma
prepper conventions in Ohio talking to
people of that nature so it was It was
kind of an all it was like an all
methods that I could think of to do and
really you know what was so interesting
to me about our project is that in that
book I didn't really talk about
electoral politics right like I didn't
really because like I felt like the
models that I wanted to bring in the
next civil war were ones that I felt I
could Define like some are stronger than
others but I could I could inform the
reader of the strength of them right so
it's like the environmental models are
incredibly strong they just are
incredibly predictively strong the
economic models are incredibly weak I'll
give you the best ones I'll show you how
they work but like they're not they're
not effective but with electoral
politics I really couldn't get reliable
information like everyone has an agenda
everyone is hiding something and that's
when that's why when you came along with
this idea I really felt like this is a
unique opportunity right like this this
is a unique chance to actually get a
reliable point of view on the state of
American of electoral politics in the
United States and you know you to your
credit you absolutely came that to me
and it's in the book yeah so what was
your experience like promoting the next
civil war the response there to uh how
how did that go well I mean it was a
year after January 6th it was very much
in the air um you know it was during uh
the Omron wave or was it Delta I forget
which one but you know I was just in
front of this laptop doing exactly what
I'm doing like six seven hours a day
talking to you know various uh like
whoever would have me which was a lot of
which was a lot of people um and like I
I think I ended up doing over like a 100
podcasts during that um during that
period but was you know um it was very
much on people's minds uh that was you
know and I think going into 2024 of
course it's again very very much on
people's minds so Stephen if someone
were to ask you hey what is this book
about what would you say I would say
it's sort of the most accurate depiction
possible of the inside of a campaign
during the last American election where
where where American democracy actually
collapses um under the weight of
distrust and under the weight of you
know a collapsing electoral system and
so it's a you know a paranoid political
thriller that's accurate so I approached
you and said hey how would you like to
collaborate on something cuz I had an
instinct and I think you shared that
instinct that were trying to get a
message out and stories are the most
powerful and effective means of actually
getting messages out um For Better or
For Worse now we're all kind of getting
pounded into
content yeah so but then I thought well
hey uh I I think we have a compelling
story here uh I have an insiders
perspective on what the heck it means to
run for president and what the mechanics
would be of a challenge from outside the
two- party system and there are various
folks who see that coming to pass in
2024 uh I had a feeling that there was
going to be something of that sort so uh
I approached you with the idea saying
look I I'd like to present a an account
of what would happen if there were
fairly strong independent Challenger for
the White House and by the way I don't
think I'm giving anything away here like
this candidate people think it it's
going to be me it's Loosely no let's
just be clear it's all a work of fiction
oh yeah yeah so no no one's based on
anybody but you know I mean but but
people could if they read it they'd be
like this reminds me of some people so
um there's there's probably a dash of me
thrown in there for
fun
but um but I had a sense as to how that
might play out and I I thought well we
we can convey a really uh true to life
uh Insider re account of what would
happen from the campaign's
perspective how close do you you know I
was interesting because I was thinking
about it today reading the New York
Times like about there was like this
piece about the rise in political VI
like the rise in tolerance for political
violence and also the uh the outside
party like like how I'm surprised how
close we're getting like I mean I
thought I you know when you write these
things and you're predicting things like
you're almost never right but I mean how
close do you think we I think we're
pretty much on track what like what we
wrote In the book we're we're not that
far away yeah I I'd say we're within
like a one to five years zone of much of
what we write about coming to pass so uh
let's walk through your process a little
bit and the writing process a little bit
so so you and I then sit down for hours
and hours and hours and I give you a
whole slew of stories I give you
projections uh I give you
conversations and whatnot and um and
then you integrated this uh journalist
in into the plot I'd say that the two
main characters of the last election now
available uh for order and book stores
everywhere um are Martha the journalist
uh and Mikey the independent campaign
manager right uh now I I certainly would
cond to the fact that um that I'm I'm
the source of a lot of the campaign
stuff but the journalist stuff came
primarily from you and your experience
you are a journalist I mean you you
write for the Atlantic and other
Publications uh so what what brought
Martha to the four in your mind well I
felt like you were giving me the real
technical information about a political
campaign and those details are they're
really fascinating to me like I like and
I they never get written about like how
dark money actually works like how a
like how that how the the video transfer
Works between uh these different
entities how you know un what unloading
the book means how Scandal management
work like how opposition research Works
how humanization coaches work like all
this stuff like very Frank and um
accurate information about a political
campaign uh with you know warts and all
right and I thought that was like that's
the strength like that's the like that's
the that's the major strength of this
book like it's you know we're writing a
political thriller but that's what's
unique about it is that it has that
information in it and to complement that
like what I thought was like only fair
was that if you were going to do that
then I would sort of do what a real what
real journalistic practice looks like
right and what the inside work of like
you know and and this is just like
things that I've known from Friends
things that I've heard from you know
being in this business for a long time
about how these things work and how
large institutions work with all their
warts and all right with all their uh
various you know bureaucracies and
bureaucratic failures and you know also
I think one of the things we really
wanted in this book was like to show
that neither of these people are bad
people but they in like inevitably bad
things occur from what they well you
know they're not they're they're they're
good people like you know the
journalists that I know are not bad
people like they they just aren't and I
think the political campaigners aren't
really either right and so uh some AR
some aren't truly but a lot of a lot of
them are not to your point like a lot of
them actually got into it to try and do
something good absolutely and like oh
and certainly they're bad guys too right
like you know like this is a thriller
like we absolutely have that sort of
thing but I just wanted to be accurate
like how does the hip Line work right
like it's actually quite an elaborate
process um that determines what stories
arrive in a news in a newspaper right
and in in a major you know in a major
newspaper and these things are of a
technical nature right they're not
they're not necessarily like uh the
choices that people make it's really the
structures that they live in I mean I
think that's what where you and I really
were in in total agreement is that what
what's interesting what the real crisis
that America faces everyone it's all
personalities and it's all these
assaults on people's personalities but
but and name calling and so on but the
truth is that the problems are
structural right and the problems are of
a structural nature and the solutions
are going to be structural and that when
you actually just show these systems
which you did and which I did I did for
journalism you did for political
campaign you see that there it's not
it's just not functional right like it's
not it's it's not the kind of thing that
can work right and so and so that's um
you know that's why that's that's where
Martha came from just like a lot of the
great female journalists that I've known
over my life over the course of my life
who are totally dedicated it's basically
a religion to them um they are they they
they basically feel that they're in
a holy practice when they're practicing
journalism and they're in these
bureaucracies which you know have their
ups and downs and they're trying to
navigate through them and so you know
she was very easy for me to create right
I mean I've known I've known women like
you've known people that resemble Martha
my whole life my whole life and admired
them right like they're my friends and
like you know so she was super easy to
create I am so pumped that the last
election is coming out September 12th
the political thriller by yours truly
and Steven Marsh the author of the next
civil war will be in stores everywhere
but you can buy your copy right now at
andrewyang.com order now and be the
first on the Block to know how the next
election turns out it has all the twists
and turns will it be the last election
let's hope not andrewyang.com for the
last election buy it today thank you
love you
[Music]
all on our side so the the joke in my
circle is that Mikey the campaign
manager is based on Zach who was my
campaign manager but he's a lot
hornier I don't know Zach married a girl
that he met on on the campaign Trail
didn't
he I I told a joke about this the other
day Stephen I was like it was a very
intense environment we're trying to save
the
country
yeah formed Zach was Zack told me the
truth about how things worked and it was
it was incredible I mean like it was I
mean for me it was just like it was like
oh wow like every every 15 minutes there
was some astonishing fact that you know
I've followed American politics my whole
life but it's like really basic things
about how things work I mean just we're
it's amazing that they're not known you
know that they're not like part like
that this process is so uh you know
opaque that it that it that it's uh that
these basic facts of how these
management is done are are you know are
unknown no so I'm I'm going to say
something that the the book doesn't get
into as much U book gets into a lot of
things but uh one of the things that
people don't really appreciate is how uh
the two parties are functioning quite
differently in this regard so the the
Democratic party 69% of Dems have a high
trust in the media and so that they they
take their voting cues from the media uh
if you look at the Republican voters
it's down to
15% um which means that if you run as a
republican you pretty much have to be in
opposition to most media uh you can see
that with Trump in the fake news and
disantis with the fake news and you know
it's um you know at best you're supposed
to have a somewhat adversarial
relationship uh and I was in many ways
uh an outsider and I considered myself a
relatively positive Outsider but in the
Democratic party there are a lot of
safeguards uh to keep someone like me
from winning in the Republican party
those safeguards are much much weaker to
the point where Trump just ran over them
in 2016 he may be poised to run over
them again uh in
24 uh and so you you
see uh this growing energy and
frustration I will say that most people
uh are surprised by the way our story
goes like our our plot goes um and one
of the the things that you and I said
was like we want everything to be as
accurate and true to life as possible
like this this isn't going to be some
kind of fantasy
fulfillment right yeah well I mean you
know obviously we're not writing a story
with a happy ending right like this is
not uh Louise Penny and Hillary Clinton
right like I mean not to be critical of
either of them because I think that book
is excellent but like that's not what
we're doing which is like a fantasy of
American political life like this is the
opposite of that this is like this is
how it is this is the reality of
American political life is like hey how
how does this stuff actually shake out
and then and what are actor's uh actions
and motivations on the
inside yeah I mean I I think that was
that was really crucial to the whole
process and I mean um I like I I think
in all honesty I think that took a lot
of Courage on your part like on my part
it really didn't but like I think for
you to actually reveal like how this
stuff works I mean you know I guess I
betrayed a little bit about about the
media Community but uh but but you know
no one likes them anyway right yeah I
didn't I mean I found the the details
very interesting of what's going on but
it isn't um you know in a way it's not
news to to many folks that that is the
way it's going on so what was the most
enjoyable part of writing this book for
you and then what was one of the less
enjoyable Parts well I think the most
the most enjoyable part for sure was
talking to your people right I mean that
was just like I mean that was just a
crashcourse education in American
political life that I mean who ha who
has that like I mean that was just a
that was just an unbelievable gift to uh
to and just just simply on a level of
human curiosity uh to understand how
these Mechanics Work I mean I feel that
that I I feel like no one no one other
than me has ever gotten something like
that you know access journalists work
for 20 years to get in to get
information that I got the first day
because our agreement was I want the
truth and then you can you can cut
whatever you want like and then we'll
work out what happens later like that
meant that I really got the truth I mean
and you and you ended up basically
cutting nothing of the truth I mean very
very little um you know like that was so
that was to me was just an unbelievable
uh unique gift the hard part I would say
well like I I mean I think we had to
write it fast
right like like it's one of those things
where it's like like it hard it's timely
like it you know it needs to be out it
needs to like it needs to be uh like if
we didn't publish it this fall it would
be too late right and so and so we
needed to we needed to uh go very very
hard and so there were it was like I you
know quite a grind over like a period of
three or four months to get you know
just to get the writing done right in
some kind of coherent way that we could
and work with um but you know it was I
mean like it was on the other hand it
was not it was certainly never a painful
process for me I mean I like writing and
I certainly like learning what it what I
learned so it was you know like it was
it was um it was surprisingly painless I
mean I've never really collaborated with
anyone before so I I I don't know maybe
I should do it more often because I I
really I I really enjoyed well I I
enjoyed it too and getting your pages
was a blast for me you would send me a
whole chunk of of pages or in some cases
chapters I'd be like ooh what happens
next uh even though I have a sense
obviously of where the plot was going to
go uh and um reading through your in
some cases Recreation of scenes that I'd
lived was really fun and fascinating
there were some differences uh and I got
to see the choices you made in terms of
what you changed and what you kept and
what you turned scenes into who you
turned characters into a lot of the
characters are comp deposits of real
people which I suppose is is very much
the norm uh and there was a point
somewhere in the middle of the book that
it felt like a world had been created uh
where no when when you're watching a TV
series or or movie uh the successful
ones at some point make you think that
okay that this uh feels like a version
of the world or another uh reality or
track um that that the the book achieves
that somewhere in the middle
and I remember having that feeling when
I was reading the chapters you sent over
and feeling a thrill I was like wow
where we're doing it I mean you do live
in a world right like the the the the
relationship between you and Zach and
between I mean it's all like it is this
kind of Nexus of meanings right that
that that that that that and I wanted to
I wanted to capture that I also thought
the thing that I really liked was even
though it's like um you know obviously
it's a dark book it's a you know a
paranoid political thriller but true
there's some there's some humor in it
there's some humor pretty much like real
life there's some humor in real life and
it's kind of dark but then but then
whenever whatever you told me that was
optimistic I believed right like you
know like it was like I I'm trying to
get a portrait of like the volunteers
and things like that and and Zach and
you were both like oh those are great
people they're just there for their
country they're like they work they they
do this work for free and it's and and
out of love for their country and like
that I mean that was another part that
because I because I was given access to
like the darkness like Frank
descriptions of dark money Frank
descriptions of all this stuff when it
was when the op the optimism and the and
the patriotism the genuine I I believed
it right and I could write it like I
believed it right like I could write it
like this is these people are not lying
these people are they mean this right
and I think that was that was kind of if
there's any hope in it it's that right
that there's lots of actual patriotism
out there right and lots of genuine
desire to make the world a better place
like tons of it that's that's not a lie
to say that yeah I often say that uh
Americans are being let down by our
institutions uh you know like the the
people are better than the institutions
you know at this point if you just to
line up a bunch of random Americans they
could do a whole lot
more yeah the institutions are really
terrible right I mean they are in refall
and I mean like well I mean that was the
point of the next War right which is
like if you look at these these are not
really sustainable processes that are
going on but yeah it's not the people
it's not I mean like the people are you
know I mean you know I live in Canada so
a completely different political system
that a pretty functioning political
system the people aren't better right
like it's not like that's not that's not
that's not how it I know that for a fact
right it's just the system works you
know a little better although hopefully
for a little long it might it might just
be occasion of holding on a little
longer but um yeah I mean I found that
like because I was getting I felt like I
was getting the real information what
was genuine and and beautiful was also I
could I could write in a really honest
way which I which I
love this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yang this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts
now
what is your favorite scene in the book
because I want people to have a glimpse
as to what happens in the book I'll tell
you mine yeah come here uh my favorite
scene in the book was the
rally maybe because it reminded me of
some of our real life rallies um but
this was a rally in Target Center in
Minnesota and uh there there all of
these things going on behind the scenes
but also in front of the camera uh you
wrote a version of a rally speech that I
quite enjoyed um it it it felt um like a
version of something that I might have
said so so that that was my favorite
scene maybe in part because it brought
me back uh you know it made me yeah uh
feel a certain way but it also felt very
very real um what was your favorite
scene well I mean the thing I I I I mean
I like that scene too because you know I
got so many details from so many
different parts of your campaign like I
got like you know the signs have to be
double sided like if the signs are only
one side then when the when the picture
comes in it's like it doesn't work right
like you don't see the so like little
details like that are just fascinating
to me like how that technical works I
mean obviously I liked writing the bad
guy right I like like those are those
are like the funnest things to write
like balfor and like you know like where
he goes and visits the tech Overlord and
his elaborate you know layer basically
like I I mean like th and figuring out
like how opposition works how opposition
research works and like how um and the
methods they use I mean it's it's a
cliche but it's always funner to write
the monsters than to write the good guys
right and um I did I did like that I
mean I also liked writing like the I
would say the the the real details of
the like you know how how you go over
Maps I I mean like the details of like
of the the Deep strategy which I which I
found like re just find really
fascinating like it's like how how deep
this like how you're thinking through
like States and things like this and and
knowing the different uh Electoral
College situations in each one and how
complicated it is and how and how
there's this huge amount of you know
basic knowledge of the of of these
systems that are elaborate to say the
least um you know like I I really
enjoyed writing those parts too just
because I I don't think that that's
really
like in in horse race politics even
though it's the key to it all right even
though it's like absolutely how it how
it runs you you understand exactly where
the two parties hate each other but
where they also are in cahoots right
like where they they also like Shore up
their influence together as a way of
like excluding and they hate each other
but they sure hate anyone other than
them more right and that that just is a
very interesting way to approach the
whole electoral system Stephen the last
time you were on the podcast we were
talking about AI which you've done a to
a ton of writing and Research In A lot
has happened in AI since then what is
the latest and what is your concern
level and as one example right now the
writers and actors are on strike in part
because Studios want to use AI to
produce content uh more cheaply and
efficiently uh what are your thoughts
well I mean I'm not worried as you know
from having worked with me about this
thing it's not like the most optimistic
person in the world right like we just
wrote a book called the last election
together but like I don't I don't think
that AI is a threat to anything I mean
what what I honestly believe is that the
the anxieties about AI in part like
never mind the the monster like the AI
is going to eat the world like those
fantasies are uh you know simply a
distraction from the real monstrosities
of the algorithms that social media has
already got us in right like like
they're they're way more dangerous
things out there with than Ai and you
know as someone who you know I've
collaborated with two things this year
one is you and the other is AI to write
a novel you are a much better
collaborator uh like the the the the
idea that AI is going to replace writers
is ludicrous like it is going to replace
some boilerplate writers but it's not
going to replace anyone in Hollywood um
it's not going to lower anyone's value
um it it's just not that kind of system
it can't do a screenwriter does and you
know so I think that you know the you
know while there are obviously real
concerns uh about a lot of things
they're mostly concerns in other fields
like they're mostly concerns about what
it might do when it's plugged into
social media or what it might do when
it's you know when it's plugged into the
justice system which it should never be
um but you know in itself like
generative AI is I don't think it's a
threat to anyone it's certainly not a
threat to writers you know I of that I
as someone who wrote a novel using it
and is doing a lot of AI projects that
I'm obsessed with creatively um like I
don't think it's a threat to
anyone hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you
I guess I should ask like we talked a
bit about like how you felt writing the
book like I wonder if you feel like how
accurate you feel we were in the end
like do you think like I I mean I think
we're prey I'm pretty amazed at how
close we're getting to 2024 like as you
know I didn't really want to give it a
date because I don't like to pick I I I
don't like the future but like it just
seemed to me like actually it could be
2024 oh yeah
I'm I'm also a little surprised by how
on the nose we are yeah it's uh and and
there so there's a lot of discussion
about this no labels Unity ticket it's
been in the news everywhere Joe Mansion
apparently is telling people that he's
going to run for president by the way so
if if you have uh Joe mansion and let's
say Larry Hogan Unity ticket uh one of
the very angry commentaries is look this
is going to throw the election to Trump
um and I talked to pollsters who on the
inside and they were said yep that's
what it
does so you know we have a different
version of of that candidating campaign
um the other major Third Party candidate
is Cornell West who uh who's pulling at
five or six% in polls I've seen I think
that's real uh I think the vast majority
of that comes from the
Democrats uh and I think that's going to
be more than the margin victory in a
bunch of the Swing states that are close
um so those two things seem very very
real Cornell West in many ways is more
real because he's a declared candidate
he's running as a green they have ballot
access in Most states that's happening
the No Labels thing is still somewhat
speculative right they they only have
ballot access in a small handful of
States they don't have a declared
candidate um don't know how real it is
but Cornell West is real and Cornell
West does not strike me as someone who
is running so he can barain
down the stretch no I I don't think he
gives a on that you know it's like
he would not care about some softcore
White House appointment to you know
whatever be the the new official
pontificator of whatever the heck like
that that's not Cornell's agenda um so I
I think Cornell is 100% real um and no
labels is probably 70% real are you
thinking that Trump is just a
presumptive republican candidate at this
point I mean that's how I mean you know
from the outside that's certainly how it
looks to me which seems to me really
dangerous in a whole other series of
ways uh yeah I think Trump's the
presumptive nominee uh the Republican
party there there was a minute when
people thought it was going to be to
sandis until he actually
arrived so so so one of the things that
I don't I tried to convey um we tried to
convey in this book I hope it comes
across to people so the one of the
fascinating elements of what's Happening
Now is that you have these machines uh
coming into gear and and trying to
destroy each other or win or whatever it
is um but you fundamentally can't change
the human being at the top of these
machines uh you can't make Ronda santis
someone other than Ronda santis and then
you you stick Ronda santis out there and
he's actual Ronda santis and people like
I don't want this
guy so people are like looking around
being like well well that's not going to
work let's find another person that we
we can actually make this work around
it's Trump unless everything were to
break right in cols around another
candidate I'm going to make a short list
of the candidates I think have the
highest ceiling yeah potentially rival
Trump I don't think it's Dan santis I
don't see that coming back uh I think
Tim Scott has a very high ceiling
interesting I don't think it's Nikki
Haley I don't think it's Pence um the
other two who I think have very high
ceilings uh are uh Vic ramaswami who has
a genuine following and genuine appeal
and also can sell fund as a bridge to
various levels uh I think you there are
a lot of people who are looking around
to santis who uh V is their second
choice um and I when I say that I mean
among real voters among actual
Republican primary voters there are a
lot of Republican primary voters would
be perfectly happy with VC uh so so that
that is right now I'd say the Dark Horse
it's going to be turmoil isn't it the
other outside possibility as someone
who's going to outperform relative to
what most people think is is Doug bergam
uh in part because Doug bergam um is a
sellfun he's even richer than V I mean
V's net worth is estimated at 600
million which is enough where he could
if it got serious bank roll himself into
tens of millions um without feeling the
the pain too much uh Doug berham is
worth low billions um which means he
could sell fund into the the tens
hundreds of millions of dollars right
which could be a very useful Bridge uh
Doug bergham just made the the first
debates most people still have no clue
who he is so uh if if he can supplement
uh his native Resources with some
genuine popular appeal he could he has
more upside so the the problem for a lot
of these customary political figures
like Pence or Haley or whomever and I
feel they pain in a way is they're
spending in my opinion probably the
majority of their time
fundraising I mean they they're just
like the average member of Congress
where um where someone like Nikki haly
or Mike Pence or Chris Christie or a lot
of these other folks they'll show up in
an early state and they'll do a thing
and then they'll disappear to a money
center the next day uh you know they
they'll disappear to The Hamptons Palm
Beach um California Texas uh and just
freaking grinding past the Hat uh and
they need to to keep their campaign
alive because every 90 days a new report
comes out saying no Chris Christie
raised 1.7 million Nikki Haley raised uh
you know whatever it was let's call it
uh 7 million um and if that number
starts to lag or fall off the track then
everyone says whoops like guess they're
not viable um whereas V and Doug can get
away with it um to a higher degree and
just be like I just plugged 25 million
in so you know campaign's fine I
remember the first time one of the first
times we talked about the book you like
I was like okay let's do like what are
the most important days in a campaign
like what like what are the days that
matter and you were like first quarterly
fundraising report second quarterly
fundraising report third quarterly
that's when I knew we actually had
something right because it's like that's
such an unromantic answer like you know
that's such a like that's such a like in
a sense a coldblooded answer but of
course it's true right and like and and
that was what that like we were able to
focus on on that like on that reality of
that sort of stuff and the day and also
the Daily Grind of like how how to how
to fund raise which you know is the
current American political practice like
I I just found all that stuff just um
like both chilling but but fascinating
too right because this is this is how it
actually works I mean do you think that
that's I mean is that the core of the
problem or is that just like one of the
many problems well so one one of the
thing I can't I can't give give things
away too much but there is a sense that
uh it's billionaires running a lot yeah
you know you look at someone like JB
pritzer who's the Democratic governor of
Illinois billionaire uh you know one
reason why he's mentioned uh in in these
lights uh and you have these machines
that are getting more and more powerful
and more expensive and then if you have
like an ordinary human uh even if
they're the governor of whatever the
heck like grun they're like oh like
I need millions and millions of dollars
to feed my
machine and so the average American's
looking up saying like ah this is
terrible like what the heck is going on
um and so who can override the machine
uh you know often times it takes a
billionaire and then the media is
complicit in this because the media is
like oh we have to pay attention to
this guy because a billionaire because
he can do it you know what I mean like
if you had like another random person be
like oh we can ignore this this fool but
then if if if the person shows up with a
billion dollars you're like oh I guess
we got to pay attention um and so that
like the the billionaire path is one of
the only ways out and and and then
people hate that because it's like well
that's super up that you need a
billionaire well it's not it's not a
good system when only billionaires can
be in power like that's not like that's
not the that's not the American idea you
know what I mean like uh or the Democrat
I you know the thing I also find really
fascinating when you explained it to me
was how the money the money matters in
itself but especially in the early days
it's almost symbolic what it means like
it means a certain kind of it's like if
Nikki Haley raises you know one you know
17 million or something like this that
that that money is actually not
particularly significant in itself so
much as it is a demonstration that she
can raise it right that that it that she
has that kind of investment and I
thought that was really interesting too
yeah the the rule of thumb is that 80%
of the campaign's money will get spent
in the final um several weeks right so
so if you're competent you're not
spending the money but people have to be
able to see that you will have the money
and can get the money and then if you
can't then you're like well you're
doomed um so there so there there has to
be that uh constant arms race uh and uh
you know and the the Press will turn on
you in a an instant if your fundraising
Falls below a certain level now there
there were times in the not so distant
past where people have overcome that
Dynamic uh John McCain had some terrible
fundraising numbers uh the cycle he went
on to win the nomination like that there
were candidates who were left for dead
and then came back um but I think things
might have changed even since 2008 or
whatever the cycle right um because uh
because the sums have gotten larger
because the you know the Dynamics of the
press have changed um frankly because
what what people are saying with their
votes has become less important um you
you know you you saw too I mean right
now they're talking about Iowa and it
used to be that Iowa was somewhat um
indicative or determinative or at least
a combination of I and New Hampshire
were were
determinative uh and look at this past
cycle as an illustration but it's been
happening more and more like Biden did
terribly in Iowa New Hampshire and then
went on to win the nomination so you're
you're so you're seeing that there are
um like the machines are getting
stronger relative to the
people this podcast is sponsored by
Express V PN using the internet without
expressvpn is like not paying attention
to the safety demonstration on a flight
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but what if one day that weird yellow
mask drops down from overhead and you
have no idea what to do it's better to
be safe than sorry that's why I
recommend using
expressvpn the network that's used by
high-end corporations for their remote
workers so that everything they do is
hacker proof Anonymous and verified I
like expressvpn because it's easy to use
one click and you're done and you can
access content that you might not be
able to see otherwise from Europe on
Netflix and other providers secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
that's
yangang and you can get an extra 3
months free
expressvpn.com
slang
I talked a little bit about like what it
was like to work with a politician which
is totally you know totally
unprecedented for me or really anyone
that I've known but I wondered what did
you think like working with a journalist
like did you feel did you ever feel
weird about it oh you know I enjoyed uh
collaborating man we should do it again
if this book does well hey guys everyone
go out and buy the last election because
then we can write the last election too
which is oxy onic but whatever turn it
into a television
show really the last election oh no next
one we'll do is the first election of
the second Republic right that's what
we'll do yeah may maybe that's a good
point an utopian book an optimistic book
well um I I found the process of working
with you to be really positive um
because uh you would interview me and
Zach and other people and you had your
own research uh from your your uh
previous work uh and then you would
produce pages and I would just come
around and say um yes yes no tweak no
like that wouldn't happen that way that
person wouldn't talk like that
necessarily uh blah blah blah um and
then and you and I seem to just be in
search of the closest thing to the truth
as possible and so you would look at it
and say well you know like if if that's
the way it would go down then then like
let's write that there was never any
like no I really
love no yeah absolutely not well it's
also things like you know at one point
I'm doing the book and you're like you
don't have a security guy in here like
there there needs to be a they needs
it's like a security guy is a huge part
of this whole process I'm like right I
mean it just never even it just never
even occurred to me right like there's
just a huge amount like that right where
it's yeah yeah so we were both tracking
down some version of the truth and some
version of the Noto distant future uh
and and that's what what excited me is
that there was a sense and I think other
people who read this have also got the
sense is like like that they they come
back and say you know I find this
eminently plausible um which is what
makes it scary um but also hopefully
valuable yeah that's the idea that I
mean that's what yeah and entertaining I
hope you know like and entertaining but
Publishers Weekly thought was really
entertaining I mean that was what I I I
was you know I I assumed we get the uh
the credit from like it being
truth-telling like I I because I we
worked hard at that you know like I
thought we like I thought we got that
but like the entertaining thing like is
a little trickier and you know and and I
and I think we've got that too which is
which is nice you know which is like
it's a it's a good bonus yeah it is
entertaining um multiple people have
said to me it reads like a movie or TV
show uh and there are folks uh in
Hollywood who are looking at potentially
turning it into uh movie or TV show um
so uh this could be coming to screens
near people hopefully people will run
out and buy the book and enjoy it um and
then X months later if it shows up on
your TV screen you can be like oh and
you can be in the no and say oh that
that happened but I I will say I'd be
excited about that because the the story
does uh read like a thriller and and
that's a credit to you Stephen it is I
mean it's just a straight Thriller right
I mean I I felt like we were I was
really trying to imitate those great
Thrillers of the 60s like you know like
like like the um seven days in May uh
men candidate um those are those are
just great great books you know and like
the political thriller as it's come to
exist a little different than those like
they tend to be a lot longer and a lot
more um you know with a lot
more sta stages and also more lengthily
written like the more more voluminously
written but I want it to be concise you
know also like I feel like those sense
of
relentlessness like that's like part of
the times we live in right this feeling
of like this Relentless mark of time
like things speeding up rapidly and you
know those old books really had that way
of building that right into the
structure of the story and um and like
that and I I wanted to get that too
because it seems to fit right it fits
the moment it fits the story it fits you
know where we are at well I'll certainly
give you credit for a lot of the the
structuring um so if people love this
book then they should thank me if they
don't like this book they should
definitely blame Steven Ste that's fine
with me my my genius uh genius
experiences so for people who want to
buy the last election you can buy it at
bookstores anywhere uh there's an audio
version if you buy it through the
publisher then you'll be supporting an
independent publisher and that's
Dynamite uh because me and Stephen
decided to team up with an indie um this
felt like uh um a more appropriate uh
publisher than a big corporate one given
that you know in some ways we're talking
about kind of like independent politics
and and whatnot it it seems strange to
to then turn to um the the big labels
Stephen it's been such a pleasure
collaborating with you on this you and I
are going to go on tour together to
various cities and if the response is
what we hope to be maybe this will just
be the first of many collaborations from
your mouth to God's ear always great to
talk to you Andrew last election check
it out be in the know know what the heck
is going to happen and maybe how we can
it because that I I will say is what
motivates me and and I dare say Steven
too for
[Music]
sure